good morning john you and i are like it
or not what
some people call social media
influencers of course i hate this it's
like calling a journalist a newspaper
subscription salesperson yeah they sell
newspapers it is not however what they
produce on the other hand the question
of what you and i and people like us do
produce is complicated we produce value
for ourselves
in the form of affirmation or status or
income
or creative joy and hopefully we produce
value for others as well in the form of
education or insight or connection or
just entertainment and actually we
started doing this at a time when income
or status like weren't part of the
equation like nobody said like
oh you're a youtuber how impressive even
now to me that sentence sounds
ridiculous though
youtuber is we have ended up in this
world a high status
job people want my job and i don't blame
them and i don't think they're wrong
it's a good job but i started to see the
problem with this back in like the early
20 teens
when like it became clear that it was
going to be really crowded at the bottom
to get noticed you have to be
better and you have to do more like epic
meal time
was a show and the gregory brothers were
like mixing amazing music with viral
videos like
these things were hard to do but there
were also ways to get noticed that
weren't as hard
they were just worse like prank channels
started to cross
lines that were definitely immoral and
also like illegal people started to have
hotter and hotter political takes and
they were
rewarded for that one thing i think
people get wrong about people who do
what i do
is that like when when people start
creating on the internet it is
never about money the actual thing they
want is to feel like they matter they
want validation they want meaning
they want to be valuable and they
believe because of where their attention
is that online creators
are valuable and so they want to be one
so that they can definitely matter and
when you're in a society that in my
opinion has done a terrible job of
appreciating many if not
most humans more and more people are
going to want to push toward that
feeling of mattering in other words
for new creators it's never about money
it's about affirmation and it's about
status there are a lot of angles to view
this moment from and i think that they
are all
important i am a creator i make stuff on
the internet so that's my perspective
and when i see every other hand during a
siege of the capitol building
holding up a phone like on a facebook
live stream
i see insurrectionists i see terrorists
i see white supremacists
but i also see influencers i see content
creators and not side by side
they are the same person i see people
who are both ends of the creator
audience relationship their ideas get
more radical
because that makes better content that
gets more engagement and then they
consume more content like that
to inform their content that they're
going to create and also because it
helps them feel righteous for making the
stuff they're making it's a feedback
loop
that can only radicalize now this isn't
100 new it's been happening in radio and
tv for decades if you can make more
money by being more radical instead of
spending more money on quality
people are gonna do that but when it's
crowded at the bottom and people are
searching for meaning and attention and
status are the only currencies
when more and more outrageous content is
getting more and more attention
we end up in an arms race of
radicalization one that is pulling
radio and tv and yes politicians
along with it i worry sometimes that
understanding something can lead to
excusing it
not what is happening here ways to feel
like you matter
include and often include white
supremacy they also can include
believing you are an integral part of
bringing down an international cabal of
child murderers if you feel like you're
one of the only people in the world who
understands the link between 5g and
kovit it's hard to deny that you
are important especially when you're
getting a lot of engagement on your
social media posts about it and i'm not
saying that they don't believe any of
these things
i think that they do because it's very
easy to believe
things that make you feel good that is
true
of them it's also true of me it's true
of you and it's also extremely hard to
abandon ideas
you are appreciated and loved for so if
i have insight here to
add it is this the words social media
influencer turn out to be
representing a much bigger and much uh
scarier thing than we thought john
i'll see you on tuesday